the Kinzie Ziegler rose to fame from her
adorable moments on Dance Moms
but the talented dancer didn't have it
easy it took years for her to gain back
confidence after being forced to live in
her sister's shadow and live up to
someone else's expectations join us as
we take a look how Mackenzie's time on
Dance Moms positively and negatively
influenced her stardom and what she's
been up to since she left the show
starting on Dance Moms we all know
Mackenzie Ziegler from Dance Moms the
adorable pint-sized dancer cartwheeled
her way to our hearts with her adorable
routines and even cuter attitude I'm
supposed to tell Abby she's a
blabbermouth seriously how could you not
love her she's had plenty of moments
that made us laugh out loud and while
there were Dance Moms dancers that
definitely had it tougher than Mackenzie
this little star had to face another
problem that would scar her for life and
take years to heal from keep on watching
to see what she thinks of the show but
first let's recap her time on Dance Moms
Mackenzie stood out from the crowd due
to being at least ahead shorter than
anyone else on the team
her solo dances often had a cute theme
despite the fact she was able to do
serious tricks like no one else but she
fell in the back as she was often
overshadowed by her sister Maddie
following Maddie's footsteps was a
statement that was used by her dance
teacher Abby Lee Miller as well as
Mackenzie herself it took a lot of solo
performances and even more rehearsal
tears before Mackenzie was finally given
a storyline of her own but despite the
fact that Mackenzie definitely didn't
have it easy on the show she was without
a doubt talented after all she was the
youngest on the elite team but still
managed to keep up with everyone else
without issues
[Music]
fans of the show gathered some of the
best McKenzie Ziegler moments that
really made Dance Moms even more
enjoyable these include the time where
she said she just wants to stay at home
and eat chips instead of going to dance
stay home and eat chips another time was
when she adorably said that she's
emotional after she didn't catch a
bouquet not to mention her episode
interviews are absolutely hilarious to
even her sister Maddie stated that you
could always find Mackenzie in the
background either yawning or looking
half-asleep we're sure you have a
favorite Kenzie moment so make sure you
leave it in the comments below
seriously Mackenzie was always funny but
she's had a really hard time to prove
herself that she's more than just
Maddie's little sister Abby Lee Miller
was often criticized for her extreme
teaching methods but it seemed that she
never let Mackenzie off the hook out of
six seasons on the show Mackenzie was
featured at the top of Abby's ranking
pyramid less than a dozen times whenever
Mackenzie was given a solo dance Abby
always made a Maddie related comment
during rehearsals is she just not his
little sister no what happened to this
popstar that was on the box
she was so set on comparing Kenzie to
her sister she even made her do the same
solo dance Abby wants to Mackenzie to
grow as a dancer and to dance like
Maddie Tudor age Mackenzie often cried
during rehearsals because of the
pressure she experienced from her
teacher
although it's a good thing to raise
someone standards and improve their
dancing it's unfair to compare someone
to their sibling success it's safe to
say Abby's teaching was definitely
traumatizing for the kids there was a
time when Kenzie made Abby cry during
rehearsals because she was so proud
I made Abby cry because I did my dance
really good but the moment didn't last
long
and everything went back to normal soon
enough Mackenzie continued to be
pressured to live up to the expectations
that were accidentally set out by her
sister after it was revealed Mackenzie
is getting singing lessons
Abby became Kenzie's manager she was in
charge of her career and was present
during her recording sessions as well as
involved in music video choreography and
casting and Kenzie got a new name maxie
along with still being on Dance Moms and
attending competitions every single week
Mackenzie now became a recording artist
in season 4 she recorded her first song
it's a girl party and debut in her first
self-titled album of January 2019 it's a
girl party video has more than 60
million views on YouTube the video also
features some of the Dance Moms dancers
including Mia
Kenzie sister Maddie and many others
that belong to the Abby Lee dance studio
you were all invited here to be in a
video for maxi seriously the chorus of
this song will get stuck in your head
it's no wonder it has millions of views
despite the fact she was starting to
find her voice Mackenzie was still being
pushed hard by Abby in order to be more
like her sister in season 5 Kenzie
proved she's a force to be reckoned with
after she beat Maddie at a dance
competition for the first time
[Music]
and after her sister became too busy
with her own projects McKenzie finally
got the attention she needed from Abby
to grow as an individual although it
wasn't all good at some point her mother
Melissa had to step in and protect her
daughter from being called names by her
dance teacher because he also had to
fight hard to dance the style she's
actually comfortable in in one of her
last solo she finally got to do hip hop
despite the fact it took a lot of
convincing Abby to allow her to do it
she also got to recreate her iconic stay
at home and eat chips line and put it in
a dance and despite the rehearsal drama
she pulled it off and put on a fantastic
show it seems to say that by the time
the end of season six came the Ziegler
family was ready to leave the Dance Moms
drama behind the final Ziegler episode
showed that Mackenzie wasn't even in the
loop on them leaving the show doesn't
know so we need not just she appears to
be totally shocked when it's announced
by her mother but just like that the
Ziegler said their goodbyes and started
new projects outside of the show saying
goodbye to the rest of the girls was one
of the most emotional moments of the
show
[Music]
but leaving Dance Moms behind gave
Mackenzie her chance to shine as an
individual life after Dance Moms
after the Ziegler's left the show it was
revealed they appear to have resentment
towards Abby Lee Miller to this day the
Ziegler sisters refused to really talk
about Dance Moms and want to just move
on with their lives Abby Lee Miller
continued to take dabs at Mackenzie
hinting that the dancer blocked her
after she couldn't tag her on Instagram
the person who managed Abby's social
media while she was in prison even
shaded Mackenzie for allegedly being
caught vaping Mackenzie later revealed
that she doesn't really keep up with her
former dance teacher confirming that the
Ziegler's don't keep contact this was
also confirmed by her sister who doesn't
really like to talk about the show we're
pretty sure Kenzie didn't have the time
to even keep up with anything
considering she's been involved with so
many successful projects projects after
Dance Moms here's everything that's been
going on with Mackenzie since Dance Moms
she dropped her star name and really
found her way throughout 2017 she's been
a featured dancer in Rumer Knowles dance
videos which reached millions of views
this group thought Mackenzie really
found her dance style without having to
follow in her sister's footsteps after
Dance Moms Mackenzie released several
songs and became quite a successful
recording artist especially for her age
in 2016 she released her first song
under her own name titled day and night
which is a collaboration with Johnny
Orlando she also released songs like
monsters aka haters and breathe and
another duet with Johnny called what if
all songs were well-received and
gathered millions of views on YouTube
proving once again that Mackenzie is a
force to be reckoned with in 2018
Mackenzie also got a role in a web
series called total eclipse which
focuses on problems teenagers face in
high school he holds him with his
glittering eye the wedding guests Stood
Still in 2017 Mackenzie was also sued by
her label kismet music after she
allegedly breached a 2014 contract deal
according to the label Mackenzie and her
mom signed a contract that would deliver
technically and commercially
satisfactory records it all went well
until McCann
stopped appearing at the labels
recording sessions it was then revealed
that Mackenzie worked with another
producer which was a clear violation of
their exclusive deal set up by the label
at least according to the contract the
label sued Mackenzie for 15% of her net
profits under the deal Mackenzie sued
back the label claiming they did not
deliver the height they promised when
she signed with them allegedly the
Ziegler's state that it was Abby Lee
Miller who pushed them to sign with the
label with a promise of Fame as of
January 2019 it's unclear whether
Mackenzie is still under the original
label and what the result of the lawsuit
was either way Kenzie continues to
release music but despite these setbacks
Mackenzie is thriving 2017 and 2018 were
definitely fantastic years for her and
we can't wait to see what 2019 will
bring she may just be a teenager but she
already toured plenty of countries and
continents around the world and not just
once she did it twice once for her day
and night tour with Johnny Orlando and
once for the Ziegler tour with her
sister both times she got to visit
plenty of USA cities as well as
Australia New Zealand UK and many many
more she has an avid fan base of almost
12 million followers on Instagram and 3
million followers on YouTube in 2018 the
Dance Moms star
released her first book titled Kenzie's
rules for life how to be happy healthy
and dance to your own beat I wanted to
connect with like my supporters more
because obviously I do that on social
media
uh-huh but I think it'd be really cool
to write of books the book is an
unexpected tell-all of her experience on
the show she revealed that she always
felt like she had to live up to people's
expectations
she felt constantly judged and having
her every move torn apart while she
didn't say any names she said that the
people nitpicked everything she did and
left behind her back she also revealed
that she didn't even like dancing back
in 2011 which was confirmed with the
interview where she says she would
rather stay at home there's even more to
her tell-all Mackenzie revealed she felt
robbed of her childhood having to cancel
every party playdate or after-school
activity because of dance she started to
regret not being a real kid with a real
life and it made her really sad and
angry the Dance Moms Fame also took a
toll on her self-confidence after she
was repeatedly bullied online when I was
younger
I was knocked down by people and I was
scared to put myself out there as the
girls grew older they became more aware
of the dark side of social media fans of
the show would post cruel comments
stating that Mackenzie wasn't as pretty
or talented as Maddie people were also
making fun of her costumes and spread
various rumors she revealed the bad
experiences made her ready to move on
from the show and the constant pressure
ruined the fun of dance but after
leaving the show Mackenzie got another
chance at scene dance from a different
perspective in 2018 she got an
opportunity to participate in a dance
competition once again this time for
Dancing with the Stars Junior although
this might have brought back Dance Moms
memories it was also a completely
different atmosphere to what she knew
from the show there was no yelling from
a dance teacher no being compared to her
sister she was there to show her talent
DWTS junior Dancing with the Stars
junior is the first DWTS show that
focuses on celebrity kids instead of
adults the show gathered several
celebrity kids from all ages and
backgrounds and made them learn and
compete new dance routines was
definitely pushing us very hard but we
want to win so it's worth it Mackenzie
has definitely had previous experience
and danced when she entered the show it
was actually something she's been
criticized for because according to the
public it gave her an unfair advantage
in fact the criticism came out from Abby
Lee who posted a throwback video on
Instagram after the DWTS jr.
announcement she said just how much
Kenzie trained before the show but
Mackenzie said that didn't really matter
when it came to the ballroom which is
different from anything else she's ever
done just like other kids she had to
practice for about five hours a day six
days a week before she managed to even
take on ballroom I'm a little nervous
nervous because I've never done before
although the critiques kept on flying
Mackenzie thrived she also got some
closure when she invited her sister
Maddie to do a duet on the show she said
that her sister is her biggest supporter
and confessed that she once thought
she'll never be good enough and
I was really sad for a while because I
felt like I wasn't good enough
Maddie revealed the sisters had a rocky
childhood and grew up in a competitive
world that would often pit them against
one another although her sister lost all
her confidence over the years it was
clear she's gaining it back through
family support and a healthy
relationship with dance well it was
clear that Mackenzie was an established
dancer on DWTS jr. it's also noticeable
that the show was able to heal some old
wound and helped her move forward
despite some setbacks in her life we're
sure Mackenzie will continue to thrive
and prove to herself that she's more
than Maddie's Ziegler's little sister
from singing and dancing to confidence
it's safe to say Kenzie's evolution is
pretty impressive
after all being a famous teenager is a
lot to take on and we compliment her on
rising above everything she's
experienced in her life so far it's
definitely not the last you'll see of
Mackenzie she has a bright future ahead
of her and we can't wait to see what's
in store while she still gets compared
to Maddie she's proving that she's her
own person and at the end of the day
that's all that matters being compared
to someone for years can definitely take
a toll on your confidence and we hope
Kenzie is in a much better place and
ready to tackle the world what do you
think did Mackenzie have a hard time on
Dance Moms what's your favorite
Mackenzie moment from the show do you
like her music discuss everything
Mackenzie Ziegler related in the
comments below and let us know what you
think of this adorably talented star and
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more
feel-good content thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]